want to make my own money yeah I want to
do my own thing and I wasn't paying
attention to reality
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah one of the biggest
fitna that we are facing at today's time
is feminism and now recently we have a
red pill movement which is now polluting
the mind of our young men in this
specific show I'm going to be talking
about feminism and the disease that it
has on our young sisters now we have a
sister here who's Somali yeah and may
Allah bless her yeah yes who speaks some
facts and she talks about how feminism
brainwashed her to think in a certain
way and how she fixed that something she
might say might be triggering to those
feminists who get bothered by some
statements of Truth Listen for yourself
guys before jumping the conclusions and
understand and this is one of the
reasons why we started bitter truth shot
which you can check out where we have a
discussion with our panel of honorable
sisters and our brothers where we
discuss these matters to pertaining to
households so we can stop the breakdown
of the family unit here's what she had
to say which I found very very profound
I'm gonna make my own money yeah I want
to do my own thing and I wasn't paying
attention to reality and reality for me
and I'm not you know whoever has you
know your opinions that's up to them but
for me reality is a family consists of a
man and a woman and the man is the head
of the family he gets the last word and
me I'm there to nurture I'm there to
mother I'm there to you know just make
everyone feel better and just do what
needs to be done just understand I need
to click with him you know we both need
I need to know that and trust that he
can take care of the hard stuff if you
met him when he was like say 17. before
you had all the careers no I would have
gotten married to an older man with the
mindset that I've got now I've got
married to an older man who's already
established and who is looking for a
younger wife and a lot of men that's
what they want because the younger you
are your fertility like you can have
more kids and he knows what a woman's
right is so in Islam they teach you
about what a woman's right is how you
know what God is how God expects you to
treat that woman if he understands that
then I trust that whatever decision he's
making is from my best interest and for
our family's best interest not to say
that I don't know what's good for us but
we're emotional creatures sometimes we
think illogically and they don't on the
weekends I would meal prep so you know
us somalis we like to have like our you
know um our big lambs and chickens and
stuff so I'd cook that on the weekend
freeze it in like little pouches so I
know Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday I like what we're having
um and so then all I've got to do is the
rice and the pasta or whatever it is
um and he would always come home and
there's always food even if I'll go to
sleep and he's finished at 11 or
whatever I've got his plate everything
done microwave his cup drink next to it
everything just set up for him so when
he comes home he can just eat shower and
come to bed December 2019 just before
covid all right I was a stay-at-home mom
and I loved it you know
um everything was covered it it you know
it was the ideal life for me you know I
would make sure that his clothes are
clean I'm ironing his clothes for him
like I'm trying to keep him
as the man do you see how she has trust
in her in her husband and how feminism
and these other world ideologies gave
you the thought process because she got
married at 29 and she was working if you
think about my dear sisters when we say
about these things and we talk about
these matters sometimes you get upset we
want the best for you we want the best
for you and sometimes we have to be
brutally honest by speaking the bitter
truth and telling you guys that this is
how we as men want we want a woman who
is obedient to us yes the word obedient
I don't care if you rip your hair out
you can't it's fine turkey is doing hair
transplant you can go and get it there
okay obedience we look for respect we
look for a traditional wife that is the
qualities we like we don't look for a
woman who's a rebel who shouts screams
out of them who acts masculine your best
form of energy that you have and you
believe me if there's any way if you
want to control your husband or your
partner is by being in your feminine
energy because that is what makes us
crumble as men let's be honest with you
that is the reason why sisters like to
have a have woken up because she worked
a career life Etc she said if you watch
it on the show that she said that she
would have loved to be in a house
nurturing looking after a child bonding
with her hearing the first words that
come out of mouth and alhamdul she came
to that realization after and she's gone
back to a feminine energy and accepted
that her husband has the last say and
this doesn't mean we want to control we
want to be trusted and that's what she
says she trusts her husband's decision
why is that a bad thing why is that
wrong and Allah in the Quran and Islam
makes that very clear that the man is
the provider and protector now this
might be that there are men in your life
husband father son whatever it may be
that do not have these qualities that's
fine we want those men to start behaving
like men and if those men have left a
bad image in your mind we apologize but
the point is the following as men we
like to be the one that's the provider
and protector and for our wives to be
obedient to what we see that is what we
want and that's why every man wants
Muslim or non-muslim it is Uprising now
because of this because men have been
abused to such a level that their kids
are being taken away from them that half
of the money has been taken away from
them and so many other things that these
men are starting to wake up so the point
what I'm just trying to say is this if
at a young age you prioritize getting
married still have your degree do your
degree getting married and have kids
Young by the age of 30 to 31 32 when
you're less fertile yes your beauty
slowly diminished at least you have a
man a husband number two you have kids
that are grown up and now you can go
back to work don't do it the other way
around where you're sacrificing the peak
of your time your value the most the the
the the peak of your beauty and
fertility and then you're using those
Peak years to not find the husband and
then when you reach 30 uh oh time's
running out the biological clock for a
man is a different for a biological
clock of a woman we want you guys to
acknowledge this and make the right
decisions for your own good
and kick out feminism out of your lives
and inshallah that we can have more
sisters like her and you know what I'm
going to say to this sister may Allah
bless her and you know what not hats off
top is off Foreign
head but that's all I wanted to say may
Allah bless and preserve this sister and
her husband and her marriage and the
family unit and protect them from evil
eye and protect them from jealousy and
envy and that may Allah Prosper the
sister and her husband that her husband
must be such an amazing a man that the
sister is in obedience and allows him to
have the last day and acknowledges that
as a woman she has shortfalls be it
emotionally what if it may be that can
have an impact on the decision-making
factors that she trusts her husband in
and we ask Allah that more of our
sisters can wake up and take the Quran
Sunnah of a feminism and the more of our
brothers wake up to the Quran Sunnah and
kick out red pill as well till next time
don't forget to check the bitter truth
show out and you know what I would love
to have this sister and her husband on
the bitter truth show amongst other
couples to discuss these matters
is raising funds to establish a Masjid
and Community Center in Norway and they
urgently need your support every person
who prays that every kid that learns
about Islam every youngster that
memorized the Quran all of this and so
much more can be on their scale of Good
Deeds click the link and donate what you
can and share the video for even extra
reward